Mass Effect Andromeda first story
trailer has dropped but there's even
more information out there thanks to
twitter I'm Tony and this is your space
faring gamespot news update Bioware
creative director Mac Walters has been
answering fan questions on Twitter so
we've been able to learn even more about
Andromeda first up while the writers
siblings names are officially Scott and
Sarah you will be able to rename them
and customize their looks the riders
will also have plenty of romance options
including same-sex and interspecies
relationships gameplay-wise Walters said
Andromeda strikes a better balance
between being a shooter and an RPG than
previous games in the series finally he
hinted at possible DLC featuring the
riders father Alec we'll have to see how
that pans out Mass Effect Andromeda is
headed to ps4 xbox one and pc and spring
2017 Bioware previously said the game
would launch before the end of March so
stay tuned to gamespot for more info on
that and for all the latest Mass Effect
news you're already in the right place